what kind of gear can you use to record
videos for learning I'm a whir and I'm a
high school mathematics teacher years
ago I started recording my regular
classroom lessons to help out one of my
students who was sick and couldn't
attend school and much my surprised
people all around the world have found
these videos useful and watch them tens
of millions of times I've been asked by
lots of teachers how they themselves can
get started and using the power of
YouTube to help their students learn if
you're an accredited educator looking to
support your classes and share your
teaching with the world then this is for
you in this video I'm going to teach you
about the kind of gear that you can use
to make videos the way that I have and
there'll be two sections first I'll show
you how to record with the simplest
setup possible using your phone this is
how I started all those years ago
and cameras and smartphones have only
gotten better since then it's also a
camera that virtually everyone already
has and with a little extra equipment
for sound you can get some really good
quality footage out of it second for
those who are interested in a more
serious setup I'll show you the
equipment I currently use to record my
classroom lessons it's a little bit more
heavy-duty but it comes with some very
useful advantages which I'll unpack in
more detail later on so let's start with
your phone the first challenge when
you're filming with your phone is you
need to be able to position it somewhere
stable and most phones don't stand up
straight if you just set them on their
edge even those that do don't stay that
way for very long as I found out the
hard way thankfully there are lots of
little holders like this one which you
can use to fix your phone in a spot so
you can shoot let me show you how it
works is really simple you just kind of
take these draw parts here and then you
position your phone in there and it'll
clip into place and there you go this
particular one has a screw thread on the
bottom which you can attach to a stand
or a tripod like this once you've got in
place find any flat surface that's about
the right height if you've got a table
or I used to put a chair on top of a
table just be careful where you place
that and then once you've got that there
you're good to go
it'll stay in its place and you can
frame up just nicely other ones like
this come with a stand that's built-in
and whichever one you like just make
sure that you can
have a position so you can see
everything that you need like yourself a
whiteboard and whatever else you want in
the show and these are pretty useful but
don't feel that you need something this
fancy if you're just starting out when I
began I just knocked something together
in this school woodwork room that fit my
phone
you could even build a stair out of Lego
if you have some of that lying around so
you have something to keep your phone
steady what next there's some simple
gear that will help you improve the
quality of what you're recording for
your students now pretty much every
smartphone released in the last five
years will record in 4k resolution and
to give you a sense of what that means
if you're watching of your back
on a smartphone it's most likely being
shown to you in full HD or 1080p
resolution which is about 1/4 of the
pixels that your phone can actually
record when we try to say is you can get
a fairly sharp and detailed image out of
this camera the biggest single thing you
can do to improve the quality of your
videos is not about what you see it's
about what you hear sound is hugely
important and there are lots of options
let me show you some of the ones that I
have here this one is the rode videomic
me it plugs straight into the bottom of
your phone like this and it's what we
call a directional mic so wherever
you're pointing your camera it's going
to get audio from that same direction as
well
a very similar one here is the shore MV
88 same idea plugs into the bottom of
your phone it's very compact which is
very handy and has some additional
flexibility for which direction the
microphone is facing as well now both of
these are great if what you want is
something really tiny and small you can
put in your bag and not have to worry
about very much but if you're willing to
actually put a little effort in
something like this is even better and
this is a rode smartlav and lav is just
short for lavalier fancy name what that
means is the kind of microphone that you
can attach to your clothing I tend to
wear mine on my tie but you can put it
anywhere on your shirt so long as it's
nice and close to your mouth because of
that short distance you will always get
really great quality audio out of it
compared to something that is a few
meters away this end here is all of the
wires it's very very long which you can
see I can use to attach to the end of my
smartphone
just like a pair of headphones and now
whatever audio is directly from here
will record onto my phone and be part of
the same video file when I press record
super super handy also really quite
affordable to be honest so if you're
willing to sort of fuss around with
these wires and take them with you every
time this is going to be a really good
option for you and the Internet has
trained us all to get used to pretty
grainy video but sound quality is
something that makes a huge subconscious
difference especially when teaching
since so much of what we want to convey
is verbal and as an added bonus once
your audio quality improves you'll also
notice that the automatically generated
captions on YouTube will dramatically
increase in quality it won't be perfect
but there will definitely be good enough
to be useful which can make a huge
difference for our students with hearing
difficulties so this is your basic
starter kit phone stand and then your
microphone if you're just dipping your
toes into the water this is where I'd
encourage you to begin if you want to go
further though let me explain to you
what my current set-up is it has all the
same basic functions but I'll show you
the advantages that you gain from using
more advanced equipment a few years ago
I upgraded to this this is a Panasonic
gh4 if you want to know more specifics
about this camera itself there are
hundreds of reviews that you can find
online but I just want to explain the
particular benefits I get from using
this for recording my lessons first
thing is you can see it right on the
front a zoom lens now this is not a
special fancy one it's the one that came
with the camera and what this allows me
to do is have the camera at the back of
the classroom and the zoom lens means
that I can capture all of the action
right at the front they can see behind
this lens you've also got a sensor in
here which is far superior to the sensor
you'll get in your smartphone and what
that means is you can handle a wide
variety of lighting situations like
typical one when you've got a projector
on the screen in the background which is
very very bright and then you're in the
front which is quite dark so this camera
can manage both of those you also got
screen on the back here it flips out but
it's reversible so you can check the
shot while you're in it it's also a
Wi-Fi enabled camera so I can control
them remotely from my phone and one of
the best things about
this is that the batteries are
interchangeable so I can swap them in
and out in the middle of a lesson or
between lessons while the other battery
is on the charger and this is something
which caught me a lot of times when I
was recording during a normal day and
your phone battery will try its best to
soldier on but one of the most intense
things it does is recording videos so
it's going to get drained very fast and
having entertaining batteries is very
handy now when it records video it
records onto this SD card this is just a
kind of memory and why that's useful is
well you can have a whole bunch of these
which have much higher capacity than
what your phone does and let me just say
I've done it many times where I've been
recording and I've had a great lesson
that I've delivered but then my phone
has run out of memory in the middle
hasn't told me until the end and I don't
have the footage from it so this is an
advantage I will point out though that
if you go this path and you have these
little SD cards I'm some laptops some
computers you can't just find a card
reader that's built into the computer
plug it in and then you can get your
video files but often you can't do that
you'll need something separate so what
I've got here is a little card reader
card just goes in the top like that and
this will plug into your computer or
your iPad or whatever you use to edit
your videos now one last little feature
on here is also on the screen there's a
little readout here that you can see the
audio signal so you can know whether
you're recording sound properly or not
and let me just say I've done it many
times where I've forgotten to record
sound I just don't have something
plugged in so that will save you I
promise
now I've mentioned a lot of options for
microphones before but because I
normally record my lessons with my
camera all the way on the opposite side
of the room
now these options is really suitable
because they have wires that just kind
of go everywhere or they aren't long
enough so that's why these days I use
one of these it's a wireless lav mic it
attaches to my tie
then the transmitting radio sits in my
pocket and the receiving radio just sits
atop my camera and this particular kit
the rode wireless go can even be used
with the phone setup we were looking at
before so long as you get the correct
cables and adapters so in terms of
shredding videos that's all the gear
i've used throughout the time I've had
my youtube channel there's a simple set
up and the heavy duty gear but both of
them can enable you to create great
materials for your students in the next
video I'll show you how I use these
day-to-day in the classroom